before the game even begins as a good
general you should understand the
battlefield okay so we say that the
chessboard is the battlefield these 64
squares are where we will make our
mistakes well it's also where we'll make
our good moves so we should understand
the battlefield before the game begins
before it again we should understand as
a good general where to place our pieces
now I was out I was watching you guys
play and you guys were not paying
attention to the center so you guys were
playing on the sides back here down here
but not in the center so why is the
center important because our pieces are
most powerful when they're in the center
let's imagine the starting position at
the start we have a bishop on c1 we also
have a bishop on f1 but I just wanted to
put this for demonstration purposes so
at the start of the game the white
bishop is on C 1 square and we like to
say that you have your army I have my
army we're going to draw an equator
between the 4th and 5th rank and I'm
going to say I have my space you have
your space these 32 squares they belong
to white these 32 squares they belong to
black this Bishop on c1 attacks two of
black squares h6 and g5 you see that now
we say or rather I'm saying the bishop
is worth to in the space count because
of the tax two squares if we could move
the bishop to a square where it would be
more effective that is to say the space
count would increase where could we move
it try yes young man where yes yes III
an excellent excellent move when we move
to the square III we attack G v h6
that's to see 5 B 6 a 7 those are three
squares so now your Bishop has become
more effective in the how controls 5 of
my attacks 5 of my squares a moment ago
it only attacked two that was an
excellent move now at the moment the
bishop attacks 5 let's imagine that the
bishop moves to the square c5 a moment
ago you are on your side of the Equator
now you crossed you're now in my
territory now how many squares is a
bishop attack still 5 okay pretty good
we're going to go deep Wow
really deep into Black's territory and
now how many squares does a bishop
attack amen
1 f8 f 6 g5 d 8
woo the bishop became more effective
inside my territory if we move the
bishop let's say here and here
now how many squares does it attack I am
still 6 d 8 b8 b 6 a 5d 6d 5
we don't say that the bishop attacks c7
because it's occupying c7 the bishop
can't commit suicide it's not attacking
itself it's only attacking those are the
squares so we've investigated and we
discovered that the bishop can attack
six squares is it possible that the is
there a square on the board where the
bishop can attack seven seven do you
know come and show me where put this on
the board seven Bravo excellent so the
bishop we say the bishop on d4 is on a
prime Square that's square the bishop is
at its most effective because it attacks
c5 b 6 a 7 B 5 f6 g 7h a 7 okay if I had
a light square bishop and the bishop was
on f1 on f1 the bishop attacks two
squares B 5 and a 6
what Square should this light square
bishop go to so that it also attacks
seven young man same same principle
right bishop efore bravo Bravo do you
notice that these bishops are in the
center of the board okay
when we say Center what Grand Master's
are referring to are the squares C 3 to
F 3 F 3 to F 6 F 6 2 c6c 6 back to C 3
these 16 squares are the center these
four squares
efore d4 d5 and E 5 called the sweet
Center they're the best squares and in
this case the best squares for the
bishop are equal
or Indy for very very simple but it goes
to show how important the center is
let's take the night on b1 at this exact
moment with an item b1 does it attack
any of my space no if we move the knight
to the side on a3 how many squares do
you attack of mine and then one if we
move the knight to the center c3
remember these are the squares of the
center how many squares do you attack of
mine yeah okay now if we move the knight
not into my territory we're on the
equator you're still on your side you're
on the equator we're on the square e for
now how many squares do you attack of
mine and that for pretty good we'll go
back a moment so when we move the knight
here you attacked for my square let's
say you cross the equator now you're
just still on the edge of the equator
but you're on my territory now how many
are you four okay are you show me come
and show me the best square for the
knight the best square for the knight
what's the best square Bravo
I'll give you another night show me
another best square Bravo
I got it no I don't pretty good okay
correct Arizona's correct he put the
Knights on to there's actually four best
squares f6e six d6 and c6 let's try to
understand why for a second when you put
the knight on f6 how many squares does
the knight attack young men correct and
how many squares of mine does the knight
attack that's not correct so the night
at its most maximum when it's the most
powerful it could possibly be can attack
eight squares that's the most but in my
territory the most it could attack a six
this knight on f6 attacks g8e eight d 7h
seven those four squares as well as d5
and h5 so that attacks six in your
territory in taxi for g4 in fact there
are a lot of squares in my territory
where your Knight attack six if you are
on c7 it would be these two squares
these two squares and these two squares
so you would attack six squares in my
territory but it's not at its maximum
the knight could be at eight when the
knight is on the d6 squared it's at its
maximum
it attacks eight squares c88 b7 f7 f5 e
4b 5c 4 but it also attacks six of my
territories so these so we would say
that these four squares c6 d 6 e 6 + f6
are the best squares for your knight now
when you're black it's just the mirror
reverse but again notice I'm going to
put the Knights here they're in the
center there in the center I can't
emphasize this enough they're in the
center they're controlling the maximum
of squares so as a good general before
the game begins you should know the best
squares for your pieces center center
now I'm going to throw you a curve no
not yet I won't throw your curve ball
I'm going to take your queen from the
starting position your queen is on d1
how many squares does it attack of mine
six I count five okay so from the
starting position
your queen attacks by the my territory I
want somebody to come up to the board
and put the Queen on a more active
Square yes young lady you do it let's
see if you can find a better Square for
the Queen where it tacks more of my
squares okay very good thank you the
Queen on d3 how many squares does the
Queen it a moment ago attack five the
Queen on d3 now attacks one two three
four that's four five six seven eight
nine pretty good you improved it by four
can you improve it some more young man
yes
okay let's put it right there
very good so what we go ahead take a
seat so what you did is you brought the
queen just across the equator okay if
you have put it on this square you would
have been on your side you cross the
equator with the Queen on d5 could
somebody tell me how many squares the
Queen attacks young man how many nine
are you sure yes of MySpace I'll be
black how many squares in myspace does
the Queen attack one two three four five
six seven right one three four five six
seven eight nine ten 11 12 14 15 16 okay
let's say you play this move now how
many squares does your queen attack
are you correct so the number of squares
that your queen attack went down when
you moved your queen out of the center
the number of squares 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13
your queen went down a moment ago
control 16 now it controls that how many
squares do I have in my territory how
many squares aren't it 16 is how many of
32 ah Wow
so your queen alone could control half
my territory that's a lot now I'm going
to take the rooks yeah the rook on the
starting position how many squares does
the rook attack of my territory
for okay I need somebody to come and put
my rook into a more effective Square
young man you're going to do it for us
thank you so much I'm good thank you
I'm very grateful that you chose a
central square how many squares does the
rook attack how many young man 10 d6 d7
d 8 squared that's three one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
the rook does not attack the square it's
occupying it can't commit suicide either
so the rook attacks ten in the center of
the board it will take a piece we'll
have to capture but the rook attacks ten
now if I move the rook let's say from to
this square fi and to this square f6 how
many squares in my territory does it
attack nine how many agree with that
that that's 9 how many think it's still
10 do you think it's 10 now are you 10
let's count f7 f8 f5 1 2 3
g 6 H 6 e 6 D 6 c 6v 6 a 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 ah we just discover something
about the rook let's say I move the rook
to f7 and to g7 how many squares does it
attack and then
and how about if I move the rook to b7
and b8 how many does it attack young man
correct
so the rook as a gen as a good general
of our army we just discovered something
about the roof it doesn't matter in what
square in my territory
it is the rook is most effective on any
square of my territory the bishops
needed to be here the Knights needed to
be on these four squares but the rook
can go anywhere the Queen needed to be
centralized so as a good general of our
army we understand that the rooks can be
anywhere in my camp now if the rook
could occupy 10 squares or attack 10
squares in this rook attacks 10 how many
in total 20 here and once again the
Queen could attack how many squares 16
so if the Queen can only attack 16 and
the two rooks can attack 20 is it fair
to say that two rooks
are more powerful than one Queen and
that's where the point count comes in
how much is the rook worth and two rooks
and the Queen so the two rooks
or to rooks so so we would say in the
point count that two rooks are more
powerful than the Queen but now here's a
funny one think about this for this for
a second these two bishops attack how
many squares yes
are you correct the two bishops attack
fourteen of white squares how much is
one bishop worth how much are two
bishops were together six correct so the
two bishops are worth six now you should
know where the Knights and the bishops
want to go okay
these are the best squares for the
knights and bishops just before you even
begin the game you should have it in
your mind that on a really good day this
would be wonderful position to have note
the geometry does this Bishop on d4
protect this knight on f6 action does
this knight on f6 protect the bishop on
e4 young lady yes or no yes or no it's
your - yes yeah correct there's this
knight on c6 protect the bishop on d4
and then and everything's protected now
if we took the two rooks we know they
could go anywhere on the chessboard they
could get pardon me
anywhere in my camp and they'd be really
really effective let's put them here do
you notice the geometry
they're not protected so this rook on d7
protects this work on e7 this work on e7
protects this rook on d7 does anything
besides this rook protect you and then
Knights also and do the rooks protect
the bishops okay that's a nice picture
right that's a nice geometry now we were
going to take the Queen remember when we
put the Queen what would be good square
for the Queen MN excellent and one other
defy you see this geometry the Queen is
very powerful the rooks are very
powerful the Knights everything is
supporting each other
notice that it's all happening in the
center in the center so I saw some of
the games when you guys were playing at
the store it was like you guys weren't
paying attention to the center once you
start to realize that your queen your
pieces are the most effective when
they're in the center you'll start to
learn to control the center your games
your results are going to improve
tremendously tremendously
I got another quick question for you
actually this is a bit of a tricky one I
just want to ask you guys this okay
you're a king how many points is the
King worth young man oh yeah what's you
how many that's pretty good young lady
priceless
zero what do you think the Kings were
pick a number five okay let's think
about this now the bishop at its maximum
can control how many squares
so the night at its maximum can control
how many squares six is correct you can
attack eight but you can control six
from the starting position there's white
King what's the space count yeah zero I
move the King up one two three
I'm on the equator I'm on the equator
how many what's the space count for
White's King how many correct now I'm
just about to I'm thinking about it I'm
not sure which may be this square maybe
this way I'm going to cross the equator
across it on a sweet center square and
now what's my space count um oh yeah
correct c5 c6 d 6 e 6 e 5 5 can the King
move to a square where it's more than
five young man what's square anywhere uh
let's say I move here what's my space
count I am eight what is my space count
here five was my King more effective in
the center then on the side now let's
think about this let's have some fun the
King at its maximum controls eight
squares at its maximum the bishop
controls how many seven good night
isn't the King more effective than the
bishop or the night
yes if the king can control eight
squares in the bishop at its maximum
control seven isn't the King more
powerful than the bishop true but we're
just trying to get a value sense for a
moment now
how many did we say the rook I forget
ten so if the King can only control at
its maximum eight and the rook can
control ten then the King shouldn't be
worth five right because the rook
controls more but shouldn't the King be
worth more than three because it would
be it's four so a lot of grandmasters
say the King is priceless it cannot you
cannot trade it for anything but at a
certain times the King can be more
powerful than the bishop and can be more
powerful than the knight but not as but
especially in the end but not as
powerful as the rook so these are ideas
that you as the general of the army
before you start the game should have in
mind control the center think about the
best P squares for your pieces and then
put them in